victoria et les lits ont été retrouvés
dans un état déplorable
sans leurs parents elles ont vécu au
moins cinq ans seule dans la nature
coucou victoria le fait qu'elle ait
survécu est inexplicable je suis le
frère de ton papa tu te rappelles tu
entends nuque au sein d'une famille qui
les aiment victoria et ligny ont toutes
les chances de reprendre une vie normale
est ce une bonne idée non
celle du fou
ces gamines sont clairement pas prête
pour ça je sais pas vraiment si je
tiendrai le coup comment réagissent t
elle à tout ça elle s'adresse aux murs
et m10 quoi ça va s'arranger
je te le promets je crois que quelqu'un
leur rend visite
je voudrais que tu me parles de mama
vous devriez déjà dormir
c'est interdit d'entrée là pourquoi y'a
quoi l'être
elle est ici dans cette maison
ah ah
tu es ma maría
historien ya quoi se moquer les marques